you
okay Sicilian I guess so but I didn't
really mean that I'm really turning this
into a Kings Indian attack or like well
not a bad Vinick setup okay yes I like
seeing this I definitely like seeing
this since it has a weakness here a d5
yeah f5 is gonna be coming very quickly
though hmm
let's see let's see let's see let's see
hmm
c4
okay cf5 is gonna happen very soon like
c4 castles Knight c3 here comes f5 right
away I'm still gonna go with that I want
to be able to post up on d5 with my
knight let's get there
alrighty and maybe Knight g5 this is a
symmetrical position if you could just
imagine my knight right here it's
identical so that's a there's a big
difference in having the knight on these
eetu e7 squares these are these F pawns
already freedom of what to do I'm
considering just moving my knight
somewhere to have my pawn free to move
but I just I'm not sure where maybe here
is best to fight for these squares okay
maybe I could get into f4 f5 maybe
all right let's give it a whirl mmm how
do you like that all right let's see
what it has in mind here oh boy really
looking at that see two square huh
rook f2 defends let's see what you got
nothing get out of there
nothing now it's gonna exploit b3 wait
you see the B file is gonna open up the
rooks gonna play to b8 and the Knights
gonna land here that's what it has in
mind sneaky sneaky 'no Sabae ston d5 oh
this has to be good it's crying out to
be played f6 and then the bishop is
cooked dead gone out of here
lights out it'll be undermined though
chop chop remove chop and then takes but
in the meantime can't I get this rolling
and secure this and he'll be a dead
piece quit your talk and make a move oh
well he's still kind of dead isn't he
this is a giant thorn if I could open up
the H file and give made over here
that'd be nice or what about this what
about this bishop somewhere exchange off
dark square Bishop squeen here mate
that's my quick thought but in the
meantime this rook b8 b5 stuff is gonna
be the plan it's the only plan okay so
actually knowing this now maybe I can
shut the plan down that black house and
maybe and then maybe move forward maybe
that would buy myself some time to do
something on the Kings side
he could be taken out my night these
nights could always drop back also to
defend g7 if that was my idea to get rid
of the dark square bishop mmm
how do I open up this position over here
I could take here this pawn can't
recapture hmm I think as a start I
should do this I was gonna play here but
Knight f6 tempo moves okay here we go I
figured I figured this much if I do this
the Knights gonna jump in here maybe
that's okay take him yeah well maybe I'm
gonna do this I want to get rid of this
night I want to be able to capture
towards the center okay I think I need
to get rid of this guy yeah my knight on
each floor wasn't doing anything hmm
this might be an opportunity to bait the
computer into taking this pawn I'm gonna
do that I think it's gonna bite it might
be good no it's not it's not biting you
see that would open the H file and I
would be able to get rid of this Bishop
and maintain my knight on this square
I'm gonna take him out he's playing
without this piece and now I could get
if I could get this out but great ah
he's not going anywhere okay I could get
this in though I still feel pretty good
about my position kingi to get the rooks
on the H file I take like this no I
dropped this pawn oh I like seeing that
Oh The Strokes gonna enter though c4 is
gonna happen
pawn takes c4 undermining e4
I somehow feel like I should have
something though oh it's not playing
that what's this Bishop up to oh it's
ready to play here oh boy oh boy I guess
here rook check oh man it's starting to
feel uncomfortable King here if I go
King here there's h5 the 10-second
warning Oh Queen here I guess ah what a
pain yeah
yepper less than 10
I guess that dropping all my pawns huh
yeah I don't have anything now ah look
at how that just crumbled huh I'm not
even sure what I'm doing now I'm
dropping more pawns
I'm definitely dropping more pawns
no you don't want to do that I'm
floundering right now it's gonna offer a
queen trade yeah I don't have anything I
guess I could try this ah ah I had hope
as soon as the position opened up in the
slightest that Bishop move was uh the
bishop that I thought was a dead piece
really sprung to life on this diagonal
didn't it hmm
you